ils en sont très fiers seul et d'île de
france c'est le leur c'est aussi une
aventure inédite intermarché s'est
associé avec trois fermes yvelinoise
vite un à jouy en josas la ferme de
bissy abonnés les la ferme de tilleur
malgré ni pour distribuer et produire le
lait d'île de france sacrée aussi je
dirais une valeur ajoutée sur notre lait
de façon à ce que nos entreprises
puissent vivre continuer à gagner de
l'argent pour continuer à investir les
voir continuer à se développer mais on
espère retrouver déjà un souffle de
trésorerie clairement et puis bah c'est
faire connaître
notre ferme notre production or notre et
nos fermes d'ailleurs ce qu'on raisonne
collectivement avec be si évident et
voilà faire connaître aux consommateurs
qui en ferme qui peuvent venir ici
visiter la ferme
en chiffres le lait d'ile-de-france ses
1200 vaches sur trois ferme et 10
millions de litres par an vendu 80
centimes la brique
il est collectée est conditionnée par la
laiterie saint denis de l'hôtel situé
dans le loiret le cinquième partenaire
on a l'assurance que le produit va être
mis dans les magasins va être valorisée
ensuite c'est à nous d'aller expliquer
aux consommateurs
pourquoi ce produit là eh bien il a de
l'intérêt pour lui en termes de qualité
produit en terme de deux prix en termes
ensuite de revalorisation au niveau 2 au
niveau des eaux des producteurs de lait
et c'est tout l'enjeu que l'on a
aujourd'hui une tentative de réponse à
la crise du lait cette brique est
distribué dans 2 137 magasins en ile de
france
initié par intermarché le partenariat
vise à développer une nouvelle filière
régionale d'approvisionnement mais aussi
de mettre en valeur ces fermes
beaucoup de clients déjà savent pas
qu'ils avaient ferme dans 78 qui font du
lait donc ça c'est important de le
savoir
ensuite ce sont des fermes qui sont
ouvertes au public donc aujourd'hui le
consommateur qui va être qui va être
curieux va pouvoir aller les visiter
pourquoi pas et aujourd'hui la qualité
du lait qu'on vend est irréprochable
donc on est très à l'aise sur le sujet
le lait d'ile-de-france est
exclusivement vendu par les
mousquetaires jusqu'au 30 septembre
par la suite ils pourraient être
commercialisés par d'autres enseignes
sur la première année pas moins de 23
mille briques de lait attendons pour une
future dégustation